everything electrolytes how to move  fully into lion avoiding electrolyte  imbalance slash cramps so sodium  potassium magnesium levels especially at  the beginning of the diet are super  important I found I needed a lot of  sodium about a third potassium and less  magnesium than that some people need  more potassium you kind of have to play  around with it I would say just add salt  at the beginning a lot of salt to your  diet and then if the cramps come start  playing around by adding in potassium  and adding in magnesium and  unfortunately it's pretty different per  person I tried like a third potassium  that's kind of what worked for me so you  can try that but even without  electrolytes the muscle cramps and  electrolyte imbalances do go away you  don't need these electrolytes forever  but at the beginning of the diet it  really really does help